I'm elwin woo and one of the things
that's sort of not mentioned but is
worth pointing out is that to avoid
building a house of cards we want to
make sure that the data are collected
all of this is sort of hypothetical or
moot unless there's data to begin with
and so I'm really excited that to avoid
building a house of cards and to have
quality data that we can talk about and
that we can address some of these issues
is we have a panel focused on the plan
and collect phase now I'm a classically
trained researcher at the social
intervention group at the school social
work here at Columbia University and so
I'm going to confess that as a
classically trained researcher when I
read a new paper or am asked to review a
paper the first thing I do is go to the
data I look at the results then maybe
I'll look at who did it or try to infer
who did it and that's really the the
meat of my work is a is a researcher and
how I evaluate that and so with that I'm
just going to sort of project how I kind
of approach science and make sure that
you folks have as much access to the
conference data if you will that is what
the speakers are going to be talking
about and the panelists are going to be
talking about i know i'll keep my
introductions a very brief as a
classically trained researcher though I
also tend to focus on methods or make
sure I spend a little bit of time on
methods and so just to make sure I
haven't had a chance to introduce myself
to each of the panelists but just to
give you a heads up on the methods I'll
give you a three-minute warning so that
we can stay on time and everybody gets
their fair share or maybe in my research
geeks vigo I'm trying to enhance inter
panelist reliability if you will so with
that I will keep my I will keep my
promise the introduced introduction very
brief I'd like to introduce Jones star
who manages the easy ID service for the
California digital library and is the
chair of the data site metadata working
group and she will be speaking on
supporting the research data life cycle
at the California digital library and
the UC curation Center
good morning everybody it's great to be
here and I'm really glad to join you
thank you to all the organizers and the
sponsors of today's event I am going to
be talking today about supporting the
research lifecycle research data life
cycle first I just want to spend a
moment to introduce you to sort of where
I am coming from as mentioned i am with
california digital library and we're
part of the university of california we
serve all 10 campuses which means we
serve 226,000 students and 134,000
faculty and staff the specific part of a
CDL that I'm part of is the University
of California curation Center which is a
partnership of folks on the ten campuses
at CDL and also in of the community
around well all of you and and also
other colleagues and we've done that
because we wanted to bring together
people with lots of different kinds of
expertise and experiences to meet the
challenges in data management and data
curation and we think that in this way
we are able to put together some new
solutions and approaches and I think I
hope anyway that that you'll be able to
see some of those as I as I continue
with my presentation today well alright
so at California digital library we do
actually use the research data life
cycle to inform how we develop our
services and approaches we think about
this actually in a really active way and
so when I was asked to come here and
talk with you I thought well this is
actually a pretty good fit and so in
specifically for example in the plan
component we have developed something
called the data management planning tool
along with colleagues and partners and I
will touch on that this morning in
addition we have a tool called easy ID
which I will also discuss with you this
morning which is a long term or
persistent identifiers service in the
collection space are some tools first up
one called data up which is a an open
source and web-based tool for a data
collection as well as the web archiving
service which enables the collection of
web web content then for data management
actually the tools I have mentioned
already as well as the merit curation
repository which enables the storage
management and sharing of research data
and all of these tools facilitate the
sharing of research data and in addition
we partner with our colleagues in the
east scholarship program and that is a
publishing platform and we are beginning
to work with them on data publishing
solutions so touches a little bit on
what David was talking about this
morning but since I've been asked to
talk with you this morning in the
planning and collection component I'm
going to focus in on those those
services and so first up is the data
management planning tool this tool
actually is a really attribute to
collaboration in all kinds of ways in
particular the development of this tool
which was put together by a number of
partners the University of Virginia
library UIUC library data one UCLA UCSD
the Smithsonian Institution and our
colleagues across the pond at the
a digital curation center in the UK and
of course California digital library the
the DMP tool as you can see on the slide
it's a kind of wizard that researchers
can use they go in and can set up the
basic data management plan that may be
required by a funder right now it's set
up with quite a few of the funders
requirements it can be configured with
additional Thunder requirements and the
other thing that is really really
wonderful about this tool is that it can
become a kind of gateway for librarians
to talk with your scholars about the
services that you have to offer in
support of research data management
because you can get it configured to
showcase your services and lots of
libraries have done this it it has been
configured with tens tens of maybe 20 30
40 I'm not exactly sure because I'm not
the service manager for this one but
quite a few libraries have actually has
configured it to showcase their
resources it has recently gotten funding
five hundred and ninety thousand dollars
from the Alfred P sloan Foundation so
look for this to actually become even
more super-powered I think of it as a
really super charged tool here's a an
indication of the take-up of this tool
it's really become quite popular and so
I really think this is a tool you might
want to take a look at I've brought some
cards that are out in the lobby I think
that you can take along with you if you
want to remember the URLs up in the
upper left hand corner but you can pick
up card on your way out and that'll help
you keep it in mind let's say oops I'm
really having a challenge so here's my
gizmo all right next up is easy ID and I
am
service manager for this one this is a
long term or persistent identifiers
service and I put it in the plan segment
because long term identifiers are not
just for data citation they are also a
key tool in data management we offer
with this tool two types of identifiers
data site deal eyes and also arcs and
we'll be adding others over time all
right I have to do an even faster
presentation than I thought and so this
is something to mention in data
management plans and I guess I have to
whip through these because i want to
show more here's an example of data
citation from dryad here's what it looks
like in a springer but i want to give
you a quick look at data up which is a
web-based and plugin for excel and so
what you do with this tool is you can
upload an Excel spreadsheet which we all
know scientists use even though they are
you know it's not really great for data
curation you can upload an Excel
spreadsheet and it gets checked for best
practices it prompts you to save it in a
repository it decides a an identifier
and then and then prepares a citation
there are cards on this in the lobby as
well here's the stats on how bad how bad
it really is how much excel is used all
right here's web archiving service which
is a tool that that collection managers
can use for collecting the ethereal web
content this is all these tools are
available outside the university of
california this tool is for you know
climate events government government
documents that are now only available on
the web and so
here's an indication of how much this is
being used and since I'm running out of
time one more one more plug for how much
we pay attention to the data life cycle
and quickly if you want more information
about this we have lots of information
about the data management planning life
cycle two different Twitter accounts for
easy ID and data up email and also if
you have other questions obviously I had
to do a really fast to run through on
these things but you can contact me
directly and i look forward to listening
to my colleagues and all the questions
later alright thank you our next speaker
is Gail steinhart who is at the research
data environmental sciences librarian at
the Albert our man library at Cornell
University and she will be speaking on
research data management services group
at Cornell
thank you to all the organizers for
giving me this opportunity to speak with
you about our experience in supporting
data management needs of researchers at
Cornell at the planning stage so I will
start with probably what's old news to
everybody in this room but it's one of
the drivers for working in this area for
us and all our peers I think and that's
the evolution of funders policies to
increasingly require researchers to
share the products of their research so
the announcement from last week from the
White House is kind of a natural
evolution in following on some policies
that have existed for a few years in the
case of the National Institutes of
Health five years or open access to
publications for a National Science
Foundation to your a two year old
requirement to have a data management
plan with every grant proposal this new
announcement now extends that so that
every major funding agencies in the US
pretty much has to within six months
come up with a plan to guarantee open
access to data and publications so we
have some work to do but backing up to
the original not the original but that
the NSF requirement for data management
plans when that came out we began at
Cornell to try and assess what kind of
help researchers would need and whether
they wanted help with data management
planning so we did a quick survey of NSF
pis and I've just got selected results
on this slide sorry it's a little bit
dark for this room if you're interested
in the whole survey there's a paper on
it in the Journal of you science
librarianship but my point here is that
in the upper right-hand corner there's a
bar graph showing responses to the
questions you want help creating data
management plans and in all three graphs
the bars are in order from left to right
yes no and I'm not sure yes is the
biggest bar or do you want help for
planning we asked a number of our
specific questions about sort of
researchers understanding and practices
when it comes to data management do your
data conform to disciplinary standards
do you generate metadata that conforms
to disciplinary standards and there are
big bars over on the right for I'm not
sure and in fact in the survey for every
question where I'm not sure was it
possible answer
at least twenty percent of respondents
picked that so a lot of uncertainty and
a real willingness to accept some help
in this in this area I know you can't
read this one in that that's actually my
point so like any large research
university Cornell actually has a lot of
services of infrastructure to help
researchers do what they need to do but
it's widely distributed so the teeny
tiny text is categories of data
management services and all the places
on the Cornell campus where you could
find that and obviously researchers are
interested in considering external
services things that come from their
domains or maybe commercial services so
my point here is just that even on
campus it's a little bit overwhelming to
sift through what's available and
personally I wouldn't mind a concierge
like figure to help me sift through all
that and find what's important so this
evolution and policies uncertainty about
day management practices and sort of
bewildering array of services that
researchers might avail themselves of
are really what prompted us to form the
research data management service group a
little over two years ago I just want to
pull out a couple key points from our
mission statement one is that it's a
collaborative campus-wide group I'm with
library there's a lot of library effort
in this group but it's really important
for the success of this group and for
researchers that this is not a library
only effort the second point I want to
pull out is that we really do bring
people in from all over campus which
brings deep expertise from different
disciplines but also functionary
functional areas so different aspects of
information technology policy things
like that and then just the last two
points are the two things that we really
do which is to help researchers create
and implement data management plans and
then to help connect them with the
research data management services that
they might need at any point in the
research process whether that was part
of a plan or not so that's what we're
about a little bit about how we're
organized the main thing to know is that
it is a virtual organization and it's a
campus-wide collaboration so there's no
new
this no no units no new staff its people
kind of assuming some new
responsibilities and the course of work
that they already do so the heart of the
organization includes a management group
and the coordinator of that group is
here Wendy maybe just raise your hands
so people can taste you down later and
then representatives from the major
service providers who are in a position
to allocate staff and resources to get
work done for the research data
management service group and the people
doing that work are on a couple of
different teams a group of consultants
that I'll say a little bit more about an
outreach team a documentation team that
maintains the website and then we
convene and disband additional teams and
task forces as specific issues arise we
report to the vice provost for research
and the university librarian we also
have a faculty advisory board with ex
officio members from the office of
sponsored programs and institutional
review board so we get input from all
directions so we make sure we really
address what researchers need and then
in the background are all those service
providers on the fine print and the
black slide continuing to do their thing
as they always have but perhaps having a
little more business driven their way
now that there's kind of a central point
of contact for researchers to ask for
help and I think we're all developing a
heightened awareness of each other
services and opportunities to
collaborate to fill some gaps so this is
our consultant group there are about a
dozen of us and like I said we come from
different disciplines from different
functional areas like geographic
information systems intellectual
property IT security high-performance
computing I know some of our peers have
chosen to have a smaller group of staff
that are more exclusively focused on
data management this happens to work
really well for us because of that
breadth of expertise that were able to
pull together and we're really able to
match researchers someone who can help
them with their specific needs all that
diversity means we had to do a little
extra work to make sure that we're all
on the same page since we do come from
different disciplines different
professional cultures
and and you know it at different points
in time may have slightly different
agendas we wanted to make sure
researchers have a pretty consistent
experience when they deal with us so the
points that I want to pull out about the
set of operating principles that we
developed to make sure that we're all on
the same page are one that we strive to
do the best possible work in a timely
fashion and when you're dealing with
grant proposals of course that means
everything is really fast right now
because it's due tomorrow the second
point I'd like to pull out is that we
strive to promote best practices and
data sharing but we do that in a way
that's prime attic and recognizes the
time and resource constraints the
researchers face and also with a healthy
respect for the diversity of approaches
that different disciplines it take to
research and research data the like I
said bring diverse expertise to the
table but also are realistic about the
limits of that expertise and will refer
people out when we reach those limits
and my next point about confidentiality
is a really key one we do sometimes need
to talk amongst ourselves to provide
that the best service and comprehensive
service but that any information that we
have about someone's research is
confidential it stays within the group
we found early on as we started
consulting on data management plans that
sometimes someone come for us to come to
us for help and be a little bit
reluctant to say much about the research
that they're doing and it's really not
possible to provide substantive input to
a data management plan if you can't talk
freely with someone about their research
so it's crucial that we guarantee people
confidentiality when it comes to
research information and then the last
point is that we're not on commission we
refer researchers to the services that
make sense for them we don't privilege
or preference cornell services or any
other services we're really trying to do
the best possible thing for researchers
so let me say a little bit about how the
data consultation for a data management
plan would unfold most people reach us
by a central help email address
and I think right away we all found us
found ourselves receiving you know being
assigned a research consultation where
the initial message told us nothing
about the research that was being done
we're all writing exactly the same
message with the same list of questions
to get the conversation started so we
started sending an automated reply that
asks a standard set of questions so that
we could start this interview about what
someone needs for a data management plan
right off the bat even before their
requests for help as a science to the
consultants so the things that we asked
for our what's the call for proposals
that you're responding to it might have
specific requirements we need to be
aware of what are your tell us a little
bit about your research tell us a little
bit a bit about your plan data
collection tell us about your
publication plans because some journals
may have specific requirements or they
may support data publication or they may
have a partnership of the data
repository that's useful to know about
and then what's your deadline how much
time do we have and then we close the
link to kind of a general data
management planning guide because
sometimes that's really all they needed
so we start collecting that information
right away and then though these
requests some help really run the range
from I need to submit a data management
plan tomorrow and I don't have any idea
what they're asking for no further
information that's where this reply
becomes really helpful to here is my
completed data management plan could you
please offer be some feedback and
sometimes those plans are very nice and
thoughtful and complete and then we see
everything in between and the
consultation can unfold from there via
email phone face-to-face meetings
sometimes they're very quick if it's
just a simple question takes a few
minutes and involved consultation with
extensive back and forth might take four
to five hours in total and the average
is about an hour so that's how that
works for us in two years we've had over
100 requests for help about 80 of those
have been for data management plans from
the National Science Foundation and
mostly we're working with scientists
life scientists engineers
and but occasionally social scientists
and humanists finest as well and I just
want to close with this that that the
demand for consultations hasn't really
slowed down since we started although
there's some predictable peaks based on
peaks and submissions to NSF so our next
presenter is George alter who is the
director of the inter University
Consortium for political and social
research a professor of history and a
research professor at the population
studies Center at the University of
Michigan his presentation title is
called collecting data in the social
sciences planning for sharing thank you
thank you very much for for including me
let's see so this is a little bit about
who we are ICPs are celebrated its 50th
anniversary last last year we were
founded originally to share political
science data and now we've expanded to
many other areas we are exist as a
consortium of member universities and
we're now over 700 universities world
worldwide about 400 in in the United
States and what we do is we archive data
we curate it we preserve it and
disseminated and we also teach people
how to use it so we have a summer
program that last summer had about a
thousand more than a thousand
participants so we've been advising
people in the social sciences about how
to manage their data for a long time
this is the latest edition of our guide
for data collection it's the fifth
edition we now have put it up on the web
so we can change it more often because
things are changing so fast and so I and
as you can see we have a data life cycle
concept there too I'm not going to talk
about everything that's in there I've
picked out some things that I think are
problematic that I want to want to
emphasize so I'm going to talk about
three areas confidentiality and
disclosure risk
provenance and metadata which are
particular problems in our disciplines
so we you know when we collect data we
promise people that there will that the
benefits of collecting the data outweigh
the harm and we have an obligation to
protect the confidentiality of the
information that people give us so there
are a number of things that people could
do to make their data more shareable if
they in the area of confidential data if
they thought about them in advance and
I'm fortunately going to have to go
through these things very fast but I did
want to mention some of them the the
biggest barrier to sharing data in many
disciplines is the informed consent
process because many up till recently
many I arbys were telling people to use
informed consents from the biomedical
community that were really designed to
keep to prevent data sharing rather than
to share it that language is actually
discouraged by by NIH and there are a
number of things that people can do to
avoid that we in our guide we talk about
some things that that you shouldn't say
and we also have some examples of
language that that people can use
secondly this is an area that is not
well developed but we actually have some
a colleague who's doing a research
project on this there are a number of
design features in the way that people
collect data that make data more
difficult to share because it's more
identifiable so there are a lot of
things like geocoding longitudinal data
that are naturally make data harder to
share but people could reduce some of
those risks if they thought about them
in advance so the simplest one I think
is
is that if people take data from one
geographic location there are certainly
some savings in cost there but it makes
it much more difficult to share it
because the the data is more
identifiable so there are a number of
things that we're we're trying to
develop to help people designs safer
designs to make to reduce disclosure
risk finally there are things that can
be done to the data afterwards to make
it to reduce the risks of disclosure and
this has become a quite a well developed
developed area and there are strategies
that people can use to share data that
does have a risk of disclosure in safe
ways and one of the the most important
ones that's that we're working on in a
number of people in not only in the US
but in Europe have been working on is
this next to last one what we call a
virtual data Enclave which is a remote
access system where the data is is kept
in in a safe location but you give
people access to it over the internet so
they can do their work so provenance one
of the biggest problems in the social
sciences is that we don't actually have
a tradition of lab notebooks if we had
lab notebooks we would be better off
people would be recording things there
are a lot of things that people should
be recording under the heading of what a
librarian or an archivist would call
Providence that people don't think of
that way but I want to highlight that
that we need to train our researchers to
think in this way and I wanted to
highlight one thing in particular that I
think falls under the heading of
provenance which is response rates if
we're going to share data openly the
people using that data need to know the
characteristics of the data so
and this is a good example of something
that's been of great concern in
political science world and survey world
response rate now you see at the top
there a national survey conducted by
it's actually conducted at the
University of Michigan for four believe
the CDC and they've got a you know
seventy-eight seventy-eight 79 percent
response rate but there's another survey
that we have in our collection where the
response rates you know are down in the
you know five percent range men you know
people wonder why some many of the
political polls predict badly well it
turns out that often they've got
response rates that are under ten
percent it's they've been a concern for
them and a poor which is an association
of polling groups now has a has new
guidelines for people to reserve this to
reveal these things well capturing this
kind of provenance information is is
extremely important I wanted to say two
things about capturing in about metadata
one is that in the social sciences we do
have a standard for metadata in 1995
icpsr met with with other leaders in the
field and began the data documentation
initiative DDI as it's known is now
gathering strength worldwide not only in
data archives but also in some national
statistical agencies it is an xml
standard for capturing metadata and
tools are now being developed both to
use that and to the DDI metadata and to
make it easier to collect so for example
at icpsr now we have some new powerful
searching tools that search at the
variable level Lincoln and will soon be
able to search for for studies that have
three one two three or more variables
simultaneously which are all built on
having rich metadata of course
provenance is one of the elements in
that but a lot more is
able to have the autumn and automated
code book there are tools currently
being developed to assist people in
collect in putting their data into DDI
which makes the curation and the
discovery much more powerful at the
moment we don't have a full workflow
that solves all the problems but I think
that that's coming we're actually
working with with two in on an NSF grant
with two of the major surveys the
American national election study in the
general social survey to analyze their
workflows to see if they can go to
capturing the metadata smoothly
throughout the whole process ultimately
I believe that that's one of the most
important things that we can do for the
researchers which is to develop
workflows and tools that like and data
up is is a good example of this that
assists them in capturing the metadata
so that we have the full metadata
because if the metadata is captured
while the data is being collected it
will be more complete it will be part of
part of their process and ultimately the
data will be much more useful so thank
you our next speaker is Michael Huerta
who is the associate director of the
national library of medicine and
director of let the libraries office of
health information programs development
he will be speaking about the NIH
initiative big data to knowledge
thank you and thanks for this
opportunity I should say that I was
asked to talk about what's new at NIH so
it doesn't really fit into the data life
cycle been very well so biomedical
research Enterprise today has lots and
lots of data NIH generates with its
funding some 30 billion dollars worth of
data every year but few of these data
are broadly available to the research
community there are exceptions like
genomic data the human connectome
project and so forth but by and large
the major public products of biomedical
research are scientific papers and the
concepts that they embody so it's so
biomedical research today really is a
concept centric not a data-centric
enterprise tomorrow we see a vision of
having liberated data by increasing data
sharing we see advances in relevant data
science and data tools ways to make data
discoverable useful to others sigh table
and linked to the scientific literature
and in general raising the prominence of
data in biomedical research in science
and in scholarship so how do we get from
today to tomorrow well about a month ago
the NIH announced its big data to
knowledge initiative for research data
and I should pause here and say really I
think the first step this initiative
will take is to take small data and turn
it into big data as David mentioned this
morning through metadata in bringing
interoperability to the small data but
this is a much catchier title so this
NIH big data to knowledge initiative
started at the NIH directors Advisory
Committee data and informatics working
group was formed co-chaired by David de
Metz and Larry Tabak it issued
recommendations for NIH research data in
three categories sharing and standards
tools and the workforce development
and we put together for implementation
groups under Eric green who is doing
this as acting director of NIH for data
science it's a position that we are
currently recruiting for the four groups
are sharing in standards and the
co-chairs and chairs are indicated here
tools tools plus where the plus is data
science and workforce development I'm
going to go through these quickly and
focus on sharing and standards in the
last of these four so the tools will
fund probably research project grants to
develop data analytics data management
data processing tools we're also looking
at large scale cloud computing for the
NIH extramural and intramural research
researchers and a way to dynamically
engage software developers and users in
the Tools Plus group we are looking at
developing 15 to 20 centers of
excellence to conduct research and
provide resources in data science and
Big Data workforce development will
include training grants for institutions
as well as short courses curriculum
development and so forth and I'd like to
turn to sharing and standards Jenny
Larkin at NHLBI and myself chair of this
group we have three thrusts the first is
on policies to increase data sharing and
to start changing the culture of data
sharing and biomedicine we see these
changes as liberating the data and they
will essentially be an expansion and a
strengthening of the data sharing
policies that NIH has in place right now
the second thing we're focusing on is
developing frameworks for
community-based standards efforts the
notion here is if somebody comes to us
with an idea for a research project we
have a framework we have workflows we've
got forms for them to fill out you know
we've got budget restrictions we got
this whole framework and we've got
support mechanisms an ro1 grant for
example if they come up to us however
and say you know some leaders of this
field have decided that what we really
need is a common data format for
functional magnetic resonance imaging
data
can you do for us NIH doesn't have a
framework we can't pull anything off the
shelf and say here you know this is how
you proceed so we're developing these
frameworks and we see that the of course
the standards will make the data more
useful to others and the community-based
aspect will make these standards easier
to adopt and promote the third area and
actually the focus of the rest of this
talk is the notion of the catalog of
information about datasets generated
with NIH funding the idea here is to
bring through this catalog and the
processes that I'll describe brief
shortly bring data into the research
ecosystem so that it's discoverable
sizable and linked to the scientific
literature each of these three thrusts
adds value I think to the enterprise and
together they have lots of synergy
especially when coupled with the hundred
million dollars or so per year spent in
the other parts of this initiative so
the NIH data catalog I'm going to
provide a use case this is still in
early stages so this is the kind of
thing we're thinking about I think this
will work but it's not certainly a done
deal we're still working on this it
starts with an nih-funded investigator
he's completed his experiments and
written up a manuscript but before
submitting that scientific paper to a
particular journal the investigator
uploads a minimal amount of information
about the data set to the NIH data
catalog which we see as an online
resource not unlike when you sign up for
conference and you fill out the little
boxes and you hit the upload that same
kind of interface would work so the
minimal information about the data set
would include the authors of the data
set which may or may not be the same as
for the scientific paper and this of
course allows proper credit to begin for
data related activities you'd also have
data descriptors pulled from a
controlled vocabulary that will be
developed and because it's a controlled
vocabulary and it will be curated and so
forth it will allow for efficient search
and retrieval of information about data
sets and the investigator will also have
to provide information about where
the data reside you know is it in
GenBank is it on his hard drive whether
the data are available for sharing and
if they're available how to get access
to those data and this of course will
promote a sharing of data once the
upload is done it generates a data
publication so it'll have a title of the
data set the authors a location in this
data catalog in terms of referencing
that publication so that provides site
ability for information about the data
set and it will generate a data unique
identifier that data unique identifier
will then be sent to the investigator
and the investigator will submit his
manuscript to the journal with this data
unique identifier in the abstract and
with a citation to that date of
publication at the end of it in the
reference section I guess so the data
will be cited as a publication because
it will be in the NIH data catalog now
when the journal when the paper in the
journal is published it goes to PubMed
for indexing and pubmed will pull out
the data unique identifiers and put it
into a separate data element in the
PubMed citation and of course the data
publication will also be published
indexed in pubmed and the same data
unique identifier will be pulled out of
there and put into a separate data
element for the PubMed citation of the
date of publication what this does is it
uses this data unique identifier as a
bidirectional direct link between the
data publication and the scientific
paper upon which that of the paper is
based pubmed will use the same
controlled vocabulary for indexing as
does the data catalog for describing the
data set what this will do is will allow
the same search terms in pubmed to be
applied so you can pull up the same
exact kinds of data sets from the data
catalog so in this example one would go
into PubMed say you want to search on
the NIH data catalog as the publication
indicate your search
terms and it would pull up whatever
datasets have used those consistently
curated search terms and all of this
information the data unique identifiers
and the citations will be able to be
ingested and used by NIH administrative
systems for things like trends analysis
and monitoring and linking publications
to Grant's into data publications and so
forth so overall our the sharing and
standards group will be bringing data
into the research ecosystem by making it
more available through policy changes by
making it more useful by using
community-based standards data sets will
be discoverable through PubMed by these
controlled vocabulary search terms and
data definitions data sets will be
sizeable because the NIH data catalog
will produce sizable data publications
and of course once you have proper
credit for data related activities as
well as site ability that provides
incentives for data related activities
data sets will then also be linked to
the literature again through PubMed in
general terms through these search terms
these controlled vocabularies as well as
this bi-directional linkage through the
data unique identifiers and finally
again information in this ecosystem can
be used by NIH and other third parties
for all kinds of I think interesting
analyses and with that I thank you
respondent is victorious Don who is an
assistant professor of statistics at
Columbia University she's also serving
on several national committees including
the National Academies of science
committee on responsible science
ensuring the integrity of the research
process and the NSF's Advisory Committee
on cyber infrastructure thank you for
the opportunity to respond to this this
fascinating group of talks so as people
were speaking I jotted down some ideas
so I'll do my best to summarize these in
some coherent form at the first one that
occurred to me is people were talking
and especially right after like we have
the privilege of being right after the
two keynote speakers and so this in some
sense can I think come into coming to
our discussion I think a lot of this
discussion really implies questions
about values and about free
coming and so this is also from the
keynotes this morning particularly
issues on why we're sharing data and
many speakers have touched on utility
and use and downstream effects and so on
all of which I am in complete agreement
with but I think there is a larger
question here about notions of
reproducibility and validation of
results and verification and I think
this is really the core of why
scientists and researchers are
interested in sharing their data at all
and this can't be forgotten in the
discussion and if this becomes a
discussion of open data is a good and an
end in itself it becomes extremely broad
and I think this is something that at
least in my background as a researcher
it's very difficult to wrap your mind
around what this means it also speaks to
this question of utility as well if we
think about reproducibility is a framing
issue it opens the door to things like
well how are these data used in research
publications it makes sense now to have
this notion of linking to a research
paper and linking to specific results it
also means that issues in terms of what
methods were used in the implementation
and software and how are these data
actually implemented or turned into
scientific findings becomes part of the
conversation as I think it should be how
have we managed to use this data and are
those tools then available to be used to
be inspected to validate existing
results I think this is really a joint
conversation between not just data that
we that support published results but
also in the software and the methods and
the code that was applied to the data to
generate those same results so this is
thinking that comes from this framing of
reproducibility so it coming down from
that sort of high level view a little
bit and speaking more more closely to
the discussion this morning I'm
interested in things like how libraries
and how the efforts that have been
described here interact with existing
repositories like for example archive
and we heard quite a
bit of discussion from George about how
this intersects with work that they're
doing in IPC sr this is something where
a recurrent theme that occurred to me as
people were speaking is who's really
responsible for what pieces of this
puzzle and how do they really come
together this is something that also
reflects from the points this morning
where we had discussions of maybe this
is something or the model should be
Wikipedia like or maybe the Internet
Archive should be involved in this maybe
it's something where there are
institutional repositories that have
been around a long time or maybe they're
involved in preprints or data and
library communities and institutions how
do they solve pieces of this puzzle
which we've seen a little bit of this
morning where are the researchers
involved George said essentially if I'm
understanding him correctly we need to
advocate for changes in the research
process this notion of this lab notebook
is unfamiliar and this is extremely
important many people this morning
touched on issues of provenance and
workflow with data this relates to this
issue of the lab notebook relates to
this issue of how we do research and
also relates to issues of code and
software that generated the results so
this all becomes part of the discussion
where do the publishers fit in where do
Open Knowledge community members fit
into this is this something that is um
we'll just sort of come together as we
do or is this something there we really
need a coherent discussion about values
and about framing to structure the way
that we move forward all of these people
that I mentioning will be part of the
solution where the funding agencies fit
in and and where is the model for how
all these different groups work together
where's the where do community members
give feedback into this so if I'm a
researcher and I'm using data that has
been carefully structured and annotated
and so on how do I tell people that it
didn't work is this something that goes
through citation system this is
certainly something that is important is
one of the arguments for open data as
we've heard a number of times this
morning is the fact that you can use
data for
research questions it was not originally
intended for it can be linked to other
data and so things like field-based
standards and vocabularies and so on
that people have been talking about
which are absolutely essential and
important there's no way they can extend
to cover all these possible uses of the
data so how do you feed back in and how
do people say well this was effective
this needs to be updated this was not
clear at all that's also I think
something that is part of the discussion
so I think I think my main point that I
want to make his respondent is not to
get mired in the details but also to
have this higher level discussion that
can help structure what is a very
complicated problem with many different
groups with many different backgrounds
and framings on how this is to be solved
what else the other point that I wanted
to make too is I see a parallel between
researcher involvement in data sharing
and in open data to research or
publication and what I mean by that is
many issues in the open access movement
and things that people have been upset
about stem from the fact that
researchers do sign their copyright over
to publishers and they willingly sign
this every time they're going to do this
publication now this is changing as
awareness of the issue has really grown
particularly over the last few years but
I also see particularly with all this
hype and excitement about big data and
data science and so on and these
collaborations with industry and data
providers who when academics were not
the data collectors themselves there are
these very similar agreements coming out
where data collectors which are often
big companies and like you know Google
Facebook who knows you know like many I
don't mean to point fingers at anyone
there's lots of them they'll offer these
data and with it comes agreements that
you sign that say things like you're not
going to share the data and this is
something where if we do the same thing
that we did is researchers when we're
publishing our papers and we just
blindly sign
out-thinking and without pushing back on
this will be in this same situation with
open access with open data and this is
something where we should know better
now with our experience with publication
and this also I think should be
something that's in our discussion and
this is something that can come from
this framing around reproducibility so
as a researcher enters into an agreement
with industry which can be
extraordinarily productive one of the
things that should be discussed at the
outset is how do I make this work
reproducible now there are all these
issues that were highlighted in our
talks to do with confidentiality to do
with and these issues can be worked
around but we need to default to this
notion that it's going to be
reproducible work we are going to have
open data we're going to have open code
and methods around this work when it
goes to publication and we can deal with
exceptions but the default is openness
sorry thank you so we have some time for
questions comments if I could actually
just make a comment on Victoria's
response she mentioned then the need for
not only data being available uh from
scientific publications but also the
algorithms the statistics the you know
software that was used in the analysis
and a particular paper for example and
didn't have time but we're doing a
software catalogue planned as well in
addition to the data catalog and that's
a very important point
I believe there are folks who will have
microphones so if you could approach
them or signal to them and use a
microphone for your question or comment
that would be very much appreciated and
necessary for the broadcast hello I'm
Daniel Kelly from elsevier some of the
speakers have mentioned this but you
know we know that universities
aggressively pursue intellectual
property there are a lot of legitimate
sensitivity issues particularly around
biomedical data and medical research
data and we also know that individual
researchers are it's very important to
them to establish priority for their
work and like we've done surveys
globally we found that eighty-five
percent of researchers say they want
access to shared data forty-eight
percent of the researchers say they were
like to share their own data so my
question of the panel is for the
individual researcher how do you
convince them to share the data because
they are often reluctant dependent upon
their field
so that's a conversation I have
practically every day and a lot depends
on the community what we see is that
there this tends to go by communities
communities in which people have done
their dissertations on someone else's
data tend to be ones where people are
more likely to share their data some
communities have have developed a
culture of secrecy and emphasizing
priority there are provisions in in our
disciplines and I'm sure many others of
what are commonly called embargoes we
prefer to call it delayed dissemination
but by which we can assure you know we
assure people that if they you know they
can have 12 months and their need to
there need to be better standards on
among the journals and among the
disciplines on when that clock begins
you know and what's what's disseminated
but it it's something that I think has
to be at the part of the community now
Michaels in a stronger position being
being at a funder where the you know the
funders can say yeah you have to do this
but but even there there are there are
ways that people can resist can I
actually if I could if I could just
build on that directly so at NIH as you
may as you saw one of the groups is
looking to revise the NIH data sharing
policies increasing the breath in and
the but also making it relevant to
particular communities and I think
that's important part and I kind of said
globally at the beginning that we're
really moving from small data to big
data but that's true so at NIH we have
certainly do of big data we've got NCBI
filled with big data and there are some
other activities where the data really
do interoperate and it would be
considered big data by pretty much
anybody but most of that 30 billion
dollars a year is providing individual
idiot
and kratika Lee configure data sets that
will need to be come together and so I
see bd2k as a major force in moving that
process forward and I also see the
policy part of bd2k as not giving the
ultimate you know uber answer but really
moving that forward and the way to do
that I think is to develop data sharing
policies that our community sensitive
and to one way to do that of course is
to bring peer review into it so if a
particular community is hesitant to
share their data or there really isn't
much of a reason to share their data
maybe that peer review process will be a
little gentler on them then if they're
coming from the community where it's
expected you're going to share their
data and they're saying they're not
going to and I think at first blush you
might think well that's not fair but
humans are humans and you have to do
things that work with human behavior and
I think this way we'll take those
communities we're sharing where they're
on the verge of wanting to share and
kind of push them over that barrier and
bring in these other communities as well
so I think it's really got to be a
comprehensive look sorry understood yes
actually if I if I might share um at
California digital library I know I did
kind of a speed-dating version of a
presentation of some of the tools that
we've built but we and i showed you
really really briefly mentioned merit
which is our curation repository we have
built in that with that tool for for
ucsf medical school clients the capacity
to create a configurable data use
agreement and that's a mechanism that
makes some researchers have a feel-good
experience about sharing their data
there's I think some questions about how
enforceable something like that is but
it's sometimes just enough to allow
allow someone to feel like okay I have a
little bit of say over at least you know
it's a
a trust arrangement with the person the
other researcher who's using my data oh
one other point if I may I thought Joan
would make the point about data site and
citation which is another important
thing here and one in which the
publishers can help one of the things
that we say to to data providers is that
if you give the data to us we're going
to put it up with the citation we tell
people how to cite data we give the data
a DOI and you'll get credit for it and
publishers can help with that by
creating standards for how data is cited
and making sure that the data is cited
in harvestable ways so that it you know
it appears in in your scholarly index
and and web of knowledge and other
places so to the to the question how do
you persuade an individual researcher
who might be reluctant to share data one
question we hear over and over again is
which data am I supposed to share and so
in conversation with an individual
research often start with what's the
publication date based on and this then
touches on the ideas that Victoria
highlighted about reproducibility and
they understand that they've shared
representations of their data in figures
so it's not a huge step to move from
sharing the figure to the data that
we're used to create it so that's often
kind of a door opener for us and and to
the other point about universities
rather aggressive interests in
intellectual property yeah we encounter
that it's especially problematic for
people who are developing open source
software or equipment and have to deal
with our tech transfer office and it's
something that all i can say is yes we
struggle with that so i just wanted to
make one point actually following on
gail's point the most compelling
argument that i found is this notion of
reproducibility i don't think there's
any scientist who wants to produce non
reproducible work and that's something
that is highly concerning to them i have
done some empirical work surveying
scientists who've
and data sharing and coach sharing and
or haven't done it and so on and I think
this was also broadly reflected in the
answers that when there are direct
benefits like oh you'll have citation
and this hat this does happen with data
and our standards absolutely should be
better but but you can pick up citations
it's not that you put your data set out
there you'll immediately get scooped on
your next paper you usually get a few
weird citations and so on from people
who have found but uses for your data
you didn't expect and then arguments
like this is good for science or this is
something that will help people and so
on tend to fall flat this is something
that the researcher really needs to see
the direct benefit that they're going to
they're going to have from this they may
agree with all this other stuff but you
know everyone's under an enormous amount
of pressure just even keep their jobs
and so on so we have to be respectful of
that I think with regard to IP issues
this is a very serious problem at the
institutional level and traditionally
tech transfer offices have been
concerned with patents particularly in
biotech and the notion the stems back
from Vidal in 1980 and the notion was
this is actually a means for enabling
transparency that the notion was there
was all sorts of technology locked up
there and if we only gave universities
institutions rights over this for
example patent rights and so on then
this could be much more transparent
because we would have to disclose it
through the patent process so this is
becoming a problem now because as we're
sharing code and software as part of
being reproducible researchers and now
we come into conflict with a tech
transfer office who says well maybe you
shouldn't be opening that quite so
widely because it's patentable perhaps
and so that is something where I think
we just need to take a very strong
stance that if transparency is what
we're about then that's what we're about
as scientists if it's money making for
institutions this is a different
discussion and I think that's something
where you know in 1983 we didn't have
computational methods and legislators
certainly weren't thinking about
software patentability in these issues
but right now in my experience with a
number of institutions the tech transfer
offices are feeling out this issue and I
don't think they've come to any
particular
resolutions on it and I think this is a
good time to have this discussion in
this debate and it's not just about
patent it's also about copyright and
ownership in software and these are
things where we need to be very clear
that what we're supporting here is
reproducible research thank you i want
to make sure we get here from a wide
spectrum of folks so i believe there's a
song to my left hi I'm Carol castle from
NYU libraries and this question is
primarily for Michael because I was
interested in your use case about you
know a researcher who's about to submit
a paper who then also submits their data
because if the data is valuable in and
of itself then what happens if the paper
isn't published right so first of all
they're not submitting your data there's
submitting information about the data
set so it's a separate process that it
makes the barrier lower the idea with
that is and they're different we've had
different discussions about how this
might be done one could imagine that
this would be done once the so there are
a couple of things and I think a lot of
this has do the fact that it was a kind
of a short and time scale here so
there's a lot of depth to this there's a
possible we've also discussed allowing
people to submit information about data
sets that are never published in a
scientific paper or form the basis there
and so so in that case it wouldn't be
particularly problematic I think that
might be the easiest way to to address
the question but our focus really is on
the scientific literature published by
NIH funded researchers that sort of
initial focus
the other panelists would like to
respond to that I believe there was a
question back there Mike roster from
Rockefeller University Press so again
I'll direct this towards Michael you
talk about you're creating a catalog of
information about data sets where does
the NIH expect the data sets to be so
that's that's a separate issue and it
will depend on for example the data
sharing plan if again if the expectation
is that the person will submit the data
to GenBank that's where the data will be
right now we have actually put together
some 45 website a portal that you can
actually access i don't have the URL I'm
afraid a 45 large data repositories
supported by NIH that accept data and
that provide data to people upon request
and we would be using that kind of thing
to encourage people to submit their data
to large repositories in all in if
that's not going to be the case in all
cases you could imagine somebody
generating a small data set that is not
there's no repository that exists for it
in that case if the data are available
for sharing they might say send me an
email now this gets back to my point
about this whole thing being first steps
so that's the ultimate answer would be
you know data what all data would have a
home and and we're not there yet but the
idea here is working toward that and I
think that as as this paradigm starts to
change a little people will see the need
or not see the need for having
repositories for certain kinds of data
so the answer is they won't reside in
any particular place but you will know
where it does reside hello my name is
Garrett clinic I have two points 1 2
Victoria was sort of a slant remark on
patents I have a quote here it says from
the US Constitution
to promote the progress of science and
useful arts by securing for limited
times to authors and inventors the
exclusive rights to the respective
writings instance discoveries I would
say a patent is a much better
publication than what we normally
publish and it's expensive to do that's
the problem the other thing is this what
you guys are mentioning is incentive
systems why should I share and we are
talking here a lot about data nobody so
far has you mentioned the word on how
others would actually truly utilize the
data what would they do with it how do
they generate a benefit and therefore
generate a benefit for the originator of
the data there's a lot of talking how
expensive it is but no talk on how
somebody actually does something with it
what's the mechanics how do they access
it is it user-friendly how fast can
zacks is it I mean those are critical
elements its usability to the end user
and therefore you generate value so let
me let me address your first question so
that that's right so patents and
copyright are in the Constitution and
they're certainly not going anywhere but
since that was written there have been a
number of acts that have reinterpreted
and made that very precise and very
specific and what it means today is not
I think you might be misled about patent
and copyright law if your source is the
Constitution and not not the subsequent
acts by by Congress so I have never
heard anyone say that they think a
patent is a better scientific
publication than a publication and I'm
presuming what you mean is perhaps it's
more clear I'm not a hundred percent
sure why you think that so but I'm
reminded of the case that the Supreme
Court heard I guess 2011 bilski which
was about business methods and software
patenting and one of the throwaway
comments in that
in in that opinion was that of course
like you know if you if you write things
mathematically of course this isn't
patentable because this is an abstract
idea and not patentable and to me the
way that I would read that which just in
casual conversation has been reflected
by others is that we actually want to
obscure in patent application so yes
there's transparency but um you know the
smallest amount of transparency you can
kind of give out is generally the most
prudent way to submit a patent and I
would also make an argument that the
Constitution is speaking about patents
across all of society I think how the
scientific community interacts with this
is very different from how
profit-seeking business model basically
most people who are in the patenting
world would interact with this and so I
would argue that right now this is a
question that scientific researchers as
a community or facing that we do need to
have some coherent discussion about this
and sort out how we go forward I mean 11
idea that I've advocated is patent
seeking and then patent licensing for
industry application and then just sort
of free and open download and use of
code for researcher applications so for
example if you wanted to validate
results as an academic researcher we use
the code I just think for folks like
this if you have to call up a tech
transfer office at a particular
institution and negotiate this it's just
it's just it's like not sharing at all
it may be very different for the for the
industry side so I've so I think they're
there a number of subtle points here at
Benden he's and copyright the IP issues
are very important for us to address I
mean we can as researchers put our heads
in the sand because we are you know
fundamentally of sharing open community
this is one of our core values but when
we start doing things on the internet
and interacting with the larger
community in this way we are just faced
with these issues and that's a fact and
we need to address them so here's where
I will do what George suggested and make
the plug for data site d lies if you get
a data site do I you implicitly agree
that you will make your metadata
freely available and that means that
when you follow one of those links you
will find what you need to get access to
that that resource that's been
registered and I think we'll be hearing
from Heather Pima bar later today she
has done research showing that shared
data gets cited more I mean it's she's
shown that to be true and so it's a
direct benefit to folks that share so I
mean I'm looking forward to hearing more
from her on that and we have something
similar over and share tools it's being
cited in event picture to prove it
shared excited right and in fact that's
the whole I mentioned we also have
software catalogs and that's kind of a
broad term we're using that we're
developing at NIH and that is part of
the issue there so the idea is to
provide site ability to to the products
of research not just scientific papers
which we have now but also data
publications and software publications
if you will there anyone else like to
respond okay one more question from the
basket the issue on copyright it seems
like everyone's like not on or not but
if it were me I would write it down as a
book and if I couldn't draw it I go on
the street and get a comic book artist
to draw whatever the patent is and I
would copyright it as a book or whatever
because the problem with open sharing
people forget I mean people are going to
Yale they're going to NYU they go into
all these medical schools and they don't
know that a black man invented
open-heart surgery these are scholars in
stem and then you have I'm Stein maybe
it's not finished yet you create the
bomb but maybe you want to create the
unball your release it as a chronic
disease so again Steve Jobs very few
people know who
Hedy Lamarr is and she's the one that
invented GPS and Wi-Fi so and leading up
to that there's this notion that you
must be sitting in the University Oh
what happened to our young friend here
14 or whatever well he was a little you
know preppy anyway besides that point
that he was outside of the box inventing
something you have the notion that some
inner-city youth some woman you know
some some some anybody can't get up out
of the sewer and invent something
fantastic like open-heart surgery so for
me in listening to you I think it's very
important that we know where the source
come from because unfortunately the
people who control data have came up
with some very interesting things Steve
Jobs Elvis Presley all kinds of crap
that is so far from reality in the
origins of how things started that it is
a danger to progress what do you think I
very much agree with you one of the most
exciting things for me personally about
working in this space about transparency
and open data open methods open
knowledge is this notion that it's not
open for people in the ivory tower it's
open and this notion that and what
undergirds that is this idea that
contributions can come from anywhere and
and should and this is extremely
valuable and one of our themes this
morning has been well how do we give the
right attribution for this and have that
source information well known and that's
something that his concerned scientists
from back when they started doing
reporting in the 1660s it's an imperfect
system I'm optimistic that this move to
digital openness will help rectify this
and allow people to learn the stories
behind the inventions and behind the
discoveries and and understand how these
things have evolved so we're getting
there it is all I can say and I think
this is really a a step forward when we
say site the data we mean attach attach
an identifier to it so you know where it
comes from I don't know what else may
correspond I think in this notion of
sort of reproducibility is one of the
advantages of data sharing and openness
I do think there's other other aspects
to what we're getting at and that would
be accountability and responsibility and
that is responsibility not just to other
scientists but to the public to the
community because that's what much of
our science is for is a social scientist
is a social worker I feel particularly
strong about that and so with that I'll
take my privilege and really end on that
note in that message because I can't
think of a more important message than
that who are we the scientists
ultimately accountable to and it should
be the public society in the community
so before we break for lunch I'm
standing between you and lunch I'll
please join me in thanking the panelists
and the stomachs
you